amazon founder
jeff bezos completed his first
successful launch into space
and the whole thing has people talking
about austin powers baby
yeah baby on tuesday the new shepard
spacecraft carrying jeff
bezos and three other passengers
successfully completed
its space flight it was a short trip but
exciting nonetheless
drawing in six hundred thousand viewers
to the live stream
on youtube oh behave yeah but people
watching the launch and getting a clear
look at the rocket
had people thinking one thing austin
powers
or more specifically one scene from
austin powers the spy who shagged me
oh hell let's just do it we always do
hijacks nuclear weapons and hold the
world hostage
just in case you need a little refresher
in the 1999 flick dr
evil's plan is to take over the world
using a giant laser
which he intends to fire at the white
house from the moon
unless they pay him an obscene amount of
money that is of course
unless you pay me one
billion gajillion civilian
commercially millions yeah of course
before he can fire the laser
dr evil has to get to the moon in his
rocket
which looked like well
[Music]
colonel you better take a look at this
radar
what is it son i don't know sir
but it looks like a giant dick yeah take
a look at a starboard
oh my god it looks like a huge
packer yeah so after bezos rocket
launched
people hit up twitter to compare it to
dr evils
one user shared this pic from the launch
adding congrats to jeff bezos on getting
so close to a perfect austin powers
reference
another user posted this side by side
writing quote
so i watched the blue origin launch and
i swear all i saw was dr evil's rocket
another person shared this screenshot of
dr evil writing
first image from inside the capsule blue
origin
and then there was this twitter user who
put it a little more bluntly
quote that's a bloody penis even dr evil
from austin powers was more subtle than
that yeah i'm pretty sure that wasn't
the aesthetic they were going for
of course this all comes after fellow
billionaire richard branson
launched himself into orbit last week
five
three two one release release
he later denied there's a billionaire
space race during an appearance on the
view
did it kind of feel good to be jeff
bezos to space
just a little um honestly not i mean i
don't know i know everybody expects me
to say yes there are far more important
things than racing
you know being seen to be racing with a
billionaire
you